Good evening.
I'm Erin Burnett.
OUTFRONT tonight, Ukraine
sounding the alarm
Air sirens blaring
across much of central and eastern
Ukraine today
as Putin's forces ramp up And tonight,
Ukrainian troops have now completely
withdrawn from solider.
Putin's forces
are making gains in the east,
but any small gains are coming at
great cost. I mean, just takes a leader.
No one knows the number of dead there.
It's really unknowable at this point,
except that it is unbearably high
for the prize of a small,
not strategically located town.
So tonight, Russia controls soliders.
So just take a look at this.
What does that even mean to control Seoul
that are that town?
Well, here's new video.
You can see it is a total wasteland.
Total, total destruction.
And it's only five square miles.
All that death for that.
And tonight,
the battle is raging on in nearby
bok moot
where two
Ukrainian fighters there
tell CNN
the situation in the city
is incredibly alarming.
Here are some new audio
that we're going to play for you.
This is a Ukrainian soldier
who is on the front line there in
listen to him
somebody, Mr.
Mahmoud.
The city of Bok
Mount is constantly under artillery
and airstrikes.
The Russians are now massing infantry,
using armored vehicles and tanks
and making minor advances.
They are climbing
like cockroaches are units
are holding their ground
and holding the line of defense.
The word cockroach is, of course,
multilayered there.
But the image
is of swarms of Russian soldiers.
And it does add to Putin
pushing the image of a massive escalation
Just take a look at this
image from today.
This is a Russian warship
armed with hypersonic missiles,
training with Russian allies,
China and South Africa. Right.
They want everyone to see
these images But, of course,
that is a powerful system.
And Ukraine's defense minister
tonight is proclaiming
that the Ukrainians now
have more to fight back.
The iron fist to break Russian lines.
And that is
because the Ukrainians, of course,
now formally have U.S.
and German tanks,
both countries
agreeing to send their top of the line
tanks to Ukraine.
The US is providing
Zielinski with 31
highly maneuverable M-1 Abrams tanks
Today's announcement
builds on the hard work
and commitment from countries
around the world.
That's what this is about
helping Ukraine defend
and protect Ukrainian land.
These tanks are a significant development
for Ukraine.
And while Russian state TV
tried to downplay the tanks, one
Russian war reporter
who has been there
on the front lines
warned Putin not to dismiss the help.
And this reporter
saying it's significant again
because it's in the context
of Russian state television
reporter said even without air support,
such vehicles
are a very serious threat
and could cause our advancing troops
a lot of trouble.
If we were talking about
hundreds of armored vehicles.
The effect could be the same
as the appearance of high margin
units at the front,
which, of course, transformed
this war months ago.
Fred Pleitgen is OUTFRONT in Kramatorsk.
That is near
where the battles are raging in
and around mood.
And Fred,
I know that you've been talking to
so many of these Ukrainian soldiers
on the ground and back.
What are they telling you about
the importance of the tanks
either there and, you know,
we spoke with soldiers
fighting on the front line
in and around a back mood.
And they were absolutely elated to hear
that western main
battle tanks could be coming to Ukraine.
In the not too distant future.
They say
tanks have been absolutely essential
to help them
hold back water for this long.
Of course, they understand
it's going to be a while before tanks
actually get here.
But they say right now
they need all the help they can get
because the Russians
are making a huge push to take back.
Here's what we're learning
the Russian army claims
its overwhelming
firepower is decimating
Ukrainian defenses
on the most brutal front in this war
around the town basement.
But if that melts away,
the 15 men just run into this house.
Brooke.
Yes. Yes. Target hit.
He managed to collapse
the middle of the building
Ukraine has now acknowledged
losing its last foothold
in the small town
solider north of Bermuda.
The Russians there mostly mercenaries
from the Varner
private military company,
judging by their own claims.
We strongly believe that
we were forced to select the target
charge up and hit it.
We had it precisely.
We hit the building right in the place
where the GM was located.
But despite sources telling CNN, the U.S.
has advised Ukraine
to withdraw from Bermuda.
Even Wagner commanders
admit
Kiev's forces are fighting back,
but they're instituting
a separate ruling
and the enemy puts up
fierce resistance to our fighters.
The enemy is holding on
and is getting additional reserves
and military supplies.
And the Ukrainians continue
probing in other areas far from Bermuda.
The military
releasing this video of a daring raid
across the Dnipro River in south Ukraine,
taking out a Russian
command facility there
But to
go on
the offensive,
Ukraine needs hundreds
of main battle tanks.
So far,
Western partners have pledged about 100.
Moscow has vowed to hit
those tanks when they enter Ukraine
and is conducting a show
of force of its own.
Sending the frigate Admiral
George Coffee,
which Moscow says
carries hypersonic missiles
to ocean drills
with the Chinese
and South African navies.
But for now, Obama is the epicenter
of this conflict.
And Ukrainian soldiers here say
they will fight for every inch
the artillery.
But one day their artillery works
and the next day infantry assaults.
It's a difficult time now,
but our boys keep standing their ground.
So as you can see there, Erin,
pretty tough for the Ukrainian soldiers
on the front line right now.
We're
also hearing from senior
military commanders
is that the Russians
are bringing more and more personnel,
but also a lot of heavy equipment
to this front line.
It seems as though they really
wants to take back mud
and also some of the surrounding areas
as well.
In fact,
the Ukrainians are saying
there's almost constant shelling
and also a lot of attempts
by the Russians
to try and breach the front lines Erin.
All right.
Thank you very much, Fred Pleitgen.